i have another chapter for you
in the maga revolt that is taking place
i told you last week that what used to
be
pro-trump and anti-trump clashes within
the republican party have now become
pro-trump versus formerly pro-trump
elements of the republican party and
this is really really good for the left
because the left has very little going
for it right now when it comes to
national political office and
campaigning as i've told you before
there's this former republican u.s
senate candidate daniel mccarthy
and we played one clip of him last week
i'll play it in a bit but i have a new
clip of him this is fascinating this is
not only a former maga guy
it's a former maga guy
who has woken up to exactly
the truth about donald trump he's a
fraud
he's a sham
and he's a liar now mixed in with that
there's all sorts of lies that daniel
mccarthy still believes but it's
incredible how what we've known all
along about trump this guy is now waking
up to listen
listen read between the lines right i
mean you know you have to understand
this guy's still a radical right winger
but listen to the critique he levies
about donald trump here so i want to
make it clear to all you people out
there that are potentially watching this
that are you know kind of haters in
regards to oh yeah oh trump oh trump's
uh part of a master operation or some
some uh 4d chess or any of that nonsense
no trump is a fraud
that's fascinating
for years these maga people like this
guy
were when trump would seemingly do
something hair brained they would say
this guy is playing some version of 40
chess he's got all the moves figured out
in advance and now daniel mccarthy is
like there's no 4d chess the guy is
genuinely a fraud and he's right
you were frauded yes and it's time to
move on quickly i think the term is
defrauded but it's i mean he's right
he's completely right and the
republicans should move on quickly
and it's time to expose him as a sham
and move on uh and potentially he should
be held accountable like the rest of
these criminals yes that have
perpetrated this fraud on the american
people that's a magga a magat i think
sometimes people call them
he has woken up you you know you talk
about going woke he has become woke to
the sham and scam and fraud
that is donald trump
and it's amazing that it took this long
but he's absolutely and completely right
i mean there's there's just no way
around it now this is the clip from last
week and here you'll see
you'll see the maga shine through
because daniel mccarthy dips in and out
of statements that make sense and
complete and utter lies remember this
hey donald trump this is daniel mccarthy
in arizona the world is waking up to
your massive grift please stop with the
smoke and mirrors with these audits stop
with your fundraising yes stop uh
establishment candidate endorsements
true stop pushing this gene therapy now
there he goes off the rails the vaccines
are not gene therapy the sauce i hear
you're coming to florence arizona for
another one of your do nothing rah-rah
session rallies that's exactly what they
are they are do nothing rah-rah rallies
he he's completely right about that well
i have an offer for you i will give one
million dollars to the charity of your
choice
if you take 30 minutes of your stage
time on january 15th
and debate me or answer my questions
even in front of your crowd think about
all the things that you've done that
you've got you've not been held
accountable for you ushered in medical
tyranny no that's not true
you exploded our national debt that is
true
you relinquished our sovereignty with
the usmca trade deal that is untrue
you passed more gun laws than obama did
with fixed knicks unclear you warned
about election fraud but yet you did
nothing to prevent it even after my team
months in advance warned you after we
were stolen from in the senate primary
you gave up on therapeutics and you push
in experimental gene therapy okay anyway
so he didn't push experimental gene
therapy or anything like that and as i
played for you last week this guy um
ultimately uh uses a flamethrower to
burn the maga hat so listen i i it it's
horrible that this is what we have to
look at as as signs of light but this is
really good for the left it's not just
pro and anti-trump republicans it's
formerly pro-trump republicans turning
against trump we want this happening
right now
some trumpists have abandoned trump alex
jones is furious with trump
former maga guy daniel mccarthy is
furious trump is feuding with mitch
mcconnell and he's still attacking his
own former vice president mike pence
this is a good thing and it will be very
interesting to see the approach that
trump takes at this weekend's rally
we'll be live with it
um trump speaks at 9 00 pm east
we will be live at 8 pm east on all of
our online platforms and i hope that
you'll join me send me your thoughts
about this find me on twitter at d
pacman and let me know what you think
about trump on former trump
violence
one of our sponsors is nebia who's
introducing their newest shower head the
nebia by moan cuatro it was designed by
former nasa engineers who spent years
researching how to save water quattro is
the world's best high pressure
water-saving shower head starting at
just 119 dollars and quattro uses 40 to
50 percent less water than traditional
shower heads helping the planet helping
your wallet still giving you the high
pressure water stream you love with four
different spray modes literally takes
one to two minutes to install easy as
screwing in a light bulb i love it i
have the rain shower version i've been
using nebia shower heads for a while now
i love saving the water and i love the
high pressure spray it's really the best
of both worlds nebia the maker of
quattro also offers sustainable bathroom
accessories i have the soft gray bath
mat and the nebia double shelf the
quattro showerhead is just 119. but
nebia is giving you ten percent off when
you go to nebia.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman the
link is underneath this video